there are three ways to define what a
sequence is unambiguously uniquely and I
just gave you one of them already here
we go
one four seven okay I can just give you
the values okay so to define one I can
just say well give me a pack I'm going
to because it's a little more
interesting for me I'm going to take
this finite series sequence and turn it
into an infinite one right so this
pattern if it went 1 4 7 if I want to go
forever
I just Chuck some dots on there it's
actually calling the ellipses but anyway
that's like a point okay doctor thought
it means keep on going and never ever
end okay now that's only one way to
define what this sequence is there are
at least two away so the first one is to
say I want to it has a function or and
where n is which term do you want like
the in term first second third term okay
so if what you're given is some kind of
function and then you can put values of
any to get which term you want thing
basically what they call this is a
formula right this is a formula for each
of the terms so if I wanted to express
this particular sequence right I could
define every single term we we denote
that my same term subscript n so that's
the nth term there if this is the first
term term one this is the second term -
two - three - four - five - six etc okay
what functioning what formula can I put
down reach it by putting n will hand me
back the term that I want okay now you
didn't events a couple of ways you can
just do it by trial and error if you
like but if we try to be a little
analytical about this right this thing
is growing how much is it going by each
time
it's going up by three every time okay
now I can keep going to be 10 and 13 and
so on okay when you think about
functions right functions what kind of
function what kind of category of
function is this behaving like I think
we all the functions you've learned by
this year this is a linear function
isn't it it's growing at a nice gentle
linear rate constant right okay and it's
gradient what's going up by every single
time is 3 ok now it's linear has
gradient of 3 so I'm gonna start by
saying 3 n ok 3 ends a good start
every time I go off one value of n it'll
go up by 3 that's what I want that's
good the only problem with this guy is
that it doesn't start where mine starts
right where is where would this guy
start this would start at 3 wouldn't it
and then we go 3 6 9 etc so how do I
adjust the short answer is yes yes when
we start to get to the sequences or
objects that start with 0 I will
highlight them in big flashing lights
and I will hopefully explain to you why
sometimes we start with 0 and actually
makes more sense than starting with 1
but for now we're just going to go with
first term T what can what be negative
ah well when you have a look at these
rules that I've given you right
is there anything stopping any of the
terms being negative not really right so
for instance if I had said okay instead
of 1 then 4 then 7 if I went 7 therefore
then one particularly the next term is
gonna be negative right and that's all
fine now where were we
we were trying to adjust this thing
because this is not the formula right
what do I have to do to it should take
away - all right because 3 6 9 is
exactly 2 more than what I want every
time are you happy with that so here is
my formula here's my function of n okay
given any nine then I can tell you
straight away which turn what the value
that happens by there's one more way
this sequence has no name I mean maybe
it does have a name but I don't know
what it is okay there are only a very
small number of sequences that we know
about that are famous enough that they
have names can anyone tell me what the
Fibonacci sequence is a very important
secret you learn about it early on it's
everywhere in nature okay there is there
is a formula there is a function for the
Fibonacci sequence but that's not
usually what you learn how do we learn
like a very very young child can make
the Fibonacci sequence how do they do it
what you do is you start somewhere you
lock in some values right and then you
say well to get to the next one just add
these and then to get to the next one
just add meat and so on okay now what's
happening is the definition for one term
depends on the previous terms do you see
that so rather than being a function of
M I have a function of the terms of M
okay do you see that it's taking a
different input okay
so where does this one is just giving me
M this one is will give me terms and I
will tell you what to do with them what
way to combine them in order to get the
subsequent ends right we call this
recursion
it's a beginner programming if any of
you software design people okay
sometimes you have a program and you
write it such that it refers to itself
which sounds like it's a bit of a
dangerous thing and it is you can make a
program at once for everyone burns your
computer but if you do it right fine and
we can do it with this one right so for
example it doesn't take that much to say
I'm just gonna leave a space per second
doesn't take that much to say but to get
the nth term you just take the previous
one and you add three said okay if this
is a term how would I state the previous
term it's going to be the one before
just by one right ten three that would
make this term - okay and I'm going to
add three that's how I get to the next
one okay but at the moment this could be
any sequence I like this could be one
four seven it could be three six nine it
could be 20 23 26 I've got a whole bunch
of different options so what I need to
do is
this into a star devalue so know what
alright once you get someone you don't
need anything else the rest of it will
take care of itself
you guys will note that Fibonacci his
famous sequence actually requires you to
lock in two initial values why is that
why do you need two values to start off
Fibonacci because in order to get to
subsequent values this recursion right
the recursion actually doesn't just do
the previous one this is the recursion
for Fibonacci right I need to go back to
alright so in order to even make a start
you need at least t1 and at least t2
because otherwise you're like what am i
two terms in a pattern okay so here are
three ways of stating what a sequence is
and you can get all kinds of interesting
sort of variations out of these I will
state one more thing which is that
remember we were doing series we were
doing binomial coefficients right those
are all series you're just adding up a
whole bunch of terms okay so you're
going to meet this notation what it's
called it's a Sigma notation right Sigma
notation Sigma Greek letter s for sum
okay and all this refers to use just
give me a number of terms it's gonna
take something like this right so as an
example this thing here I could write
this using Sigma notation this would be
let's think about this the sum from n is
1 up to 3 the third term of 3 and minus
2 that's what every term looks like ok
so this means take this for N equals 1
and this for N equals 2 and this / N
equals 3 and then Adamawa that's all ok
so familiar notation but we're putting
it to a news